[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com there is a really I would
call it more sad than anything else case
in New York State where a judge has
decided that 30 year old Michael rotondo
has to leave his parents house and the
couple the parents of Michael Rotondo
wanted their son to move out of the
house he was refusing and the parents
had to move for an eviction and of
course there's sort of the legal
complexities of it is that he is not a
tenant right when you have a landlord
tenant situation the meaning of an
eviction is much more straightforward
and sort of understandable when you have
a situation where it is your son the
concept of an eviction is a much more
complex one and ultimately the judge
here has decided that he's going to have
to leave because the son ignored them
verbally saying that they want him out
the son ignored them giving him written
notes that they want him to leave and
ultimately even an offer of $1,000 as a
sort of bridged to helping him find a
place to live
did not work and the judge says he's
gonna have to go yeah I don't think the
son really had a case here I mean if he
was a tenant I could understand tenants
have a few rights maybe it would be a
couple months before they had to vacate
the apartment yeah but if you're just
kind of squatting I guess for lack of a
better term at your parents place and
you're 30 years old and they say it's
time for you to move on yeah what
recourse do you have you don't really
right if we're talking about it someone
who's not 18 right if it's a legal child
who's not emancipated then that's a very
very different situation but you're
basically just talking about an adult
who's there without paying rent and
refusing to leave and the fact that it
is their son if there's not you know if
you have somebody who's developmentally
delayed and is like legally under the
guardianship of the parents that would
be a different situation but we're just
talking about a 30 year old guy here I
watched a little bit of the court
hearing and
he was actually doing a pretty good job
speaking to the judge using the right
legal terms I mean he could go on to
have a good career maybe in law maybe
somewhere else but he definitely has
talents I think there's some hope for
this guy
is the video super depressing I haven't
watched the video like just on a
principle because you know what it is
it's going on yeah it's not depressing I
would recommend like the first minute or
so I also wouldn't be surprised if this
guy starts like a GoFundMe page right
and raises an absurd amount of money for
a new apartment though I would people I
mean listen people donate to a lot of
different things but what would be the
pitch for why you should donate to this
guy there wouldn't be a good one but
it's the internet David and stuff
happens on the internet that is
outrageous and undeserved all the time
like am i lacking empathy or sympathy
because I'm saying it doesn't seem like
a GoFundMe is the right thing like this
is not an individual from an
underprivileged upbringing this is not
an individual who's in you know anything
approaching a war-torn scenario it's
just a guy who as far as we know just
doesn't want to go out and get his own
place let's give him a little bit of
sympathy because if he wasn't planning
on moving out and it turns out he has to
move out today yeah and he has no
options he doesn't have any money saved
up or a job I mean it's going to take
him a little bit of time before he gets
things under control if it was oh he
gets that little bit of sympathy but
he's had warnings for months so I won't
feel too bad for this guy
your sympathy level is very low it's not
like it's more than zero but it's pretty
low why do you think this became such a
big case I mean rather because parents
don't usually evict their kids who are
living at home right I mean it's not
usually it I think part of it is because
people are fascinated by disaster porn
so to speak and the idea of a
parent-child relationship getting to the
point where the parents are evicting
their kid I think is just salacious in a
way that's sort of like I'm it's
appealing to people to read about I
think I think it's as simple as that I
think you can come live here at David
Pakman show studios yeah let's base for
him no showers and our lease
specifically prevents living at the
buildings that would be would be pretty
pretty tough okay let's talk about
quitting smoking
there's this idea which we actually
recently talked about did we do the
story about the exploding east cigarette
we just week
I don't know my concept of time has gone
out the window it could have been two
months ago could have been yesterday
yeah I think it was last week I'm pretty
sure about that anyway we did this story
a couple of last week or the week before
about an exploding east cigarette and in
that story we talked about how there's
this idea that smokers switching to
e-cigarettes can be can more effectively
quit smoking altogether right that's the
gist of it you use e-cigarettes as a
bridge to not smoking at all there's
been a study done that compared very
large clinical trial that looked at five
different smoking cessation methods and
the out of the 6,000 smoke first of all
listen to these numbers out of the 6,000
smokers who were in the trial only 80
were able to provide biochemical
evidence that they were no longer
smoking six month after their quit date
so that's a very very low success rate
only 1.3 percent but if you even look at
the group that had temporary success
even if they ultimately relapsed it
turns out that e-cigarettes are not
actually that effective of a means to
ultimately quit smoking altogether but
that just paying people money Wow was
the most effective method which quite
frankly is not very surprising yeah I
don't think so surprising at all you
ever see those ad campaigns from above
the influence and those other
associations they'll talk about how much
money you'll save if you quit smoking
cigarettes because if you think about it
if a pack of cigarettes is like what ten
dollars depends on the state depends on
the amount you have to pay in the syntax
right um that adds up to nearly four
grand per year that's a whole bunch of
money so if you're saving that Plus
you're giving it a bit extra as an
incentive I would definitely quit and
the truth is that the amount of money
that smokers save also often isn't that
motivational because the idea of saving
money is we know that when you save 10
bucks it doesn't trigger the same sort
of dopamine response as when you buy an
item for 10 bucks even though you're
either exchanging 10 dollars for an item
of ten dollars of value or you are
having 10 more dollars in your account
that you didn't spend mathematically you
would think actually just keeping the 10
dollars especially
consider that the item you buy
depreciates or becomes less interesting
over time the $10 you saved should
actually be more influential it doesn't
trigger the same dopamine response which
is where like smoke a shopping addiction
can come from type of thing so I
actually know of movements to sort of
like retrain yourself where and the way
you do it is an idea is if you're about
to spend 20 bucks on something and you
say do I really need that you say you
know what
instead of buying this item for 10 bucks
for 20 bucks I'm going to transfer the
20 dollars out of my checking account
into my savings account that can trigger
a similar dopamine type response as just
buying the $20 item seeing your savings
account go up by 20 bucks and it's an
interesting sort of I hate using the
term a hack but it's an interesting
mechanism that some people have used to
try to encourage saving in a way that is
just as sort of rewarding as spending
and anyway we're kind of off track from
from the smoking thing but paying people
not to smoke is the most effective I
know what this reminds me of when I was
in college I had a friend who is kind of
shy yep not very outgoing and you know
this is gonna sound very pickup artistry
but we went out to a party once okay and
I told him before the party
you should give you should go to the ACM
take out $100 in 20s right five 20s give
it to me and every time you talk to a
girl I'll give you $20 back okay and so
the idea was he had to speak to five
females before the end of the night
otherwise he'd be losing money okay and
because there was that out of incentive
of you know not getting to meet someone
but also losing money that encouraged
him to go out there and be outgoing and
he actually had a great time Wow
so I think this connects in some way but
we may have to help me with that
well he's now in prison so that story
ultimately did not work out very well it
was all just a scheme for me to make a
hundred bucks I mean yeah right that's
interesting no I mean listen it's not
shocking that in most areas of life
financial incentives work really well
and sometimes better than we would
imagine and it seems with smoking just
giving people money works way better
than free smoking cessation aids like
the patch and nicotine gum and whatever
else works better than a transition to
e-cigarettes the best thing is just
paying smokers not to smoke okay I've
talked before about how I do not have an
Amazon Kindle and I read physical books
and every time people write in and they
say oh David it's a stupid and you know
you're so outdated and blah blah blah
part of it for me is that I don't find
the act of reading on a physical device
relaxing in the way that I find just
reading a physical fiction book is
before going to bed combined with the
fact that the blue light
not literally blue but blue what's it
called blue not blue coded light wave
anyway the blue wavelengths exactly can
be stimulative to the brain and not
encouraged
sleep sleep fulness and I know that
Kindles and those types of devices have
screens that that don't have that but
certainly like reading on a normal
tablet or smartphone at least with
default settings would have that so I
tend to not do all of my bedtime reading
on physical books I also have on my
phone I have a blue light filter which
is standard on my phone which at sundown
or even I think I have it set at 7:00
p.m. which I guess depending on when in
the year it is could be before after
sundown my phone screen changes and it
eliminates those blue wavelengths and
there's now a study which actually says
that if you use a tablet or smartphone
to read in bed it interferes with I'm
forgetting the name of rhythm no no
what's a melatonin
oh yeah blanked on it it interferes with
melatonin response and melatonin
production and it is generally just not
good for sleeping so nothing surprising
this has been pretty widely known for
some time this is yet another study
where people were studied closely it was
done in a sleep lab and I am always
skeptical of studies done in sleep labs
the problem with observing sleep in
general and especially in sleep labs is
the sort of observer effect which is
people are in a sleep lab and that's not
the down hold place where people go to
sleep fixing outs out of their
environment you're taking them outside
of their environment but all else being
equal what they were trying to isolate
here was just the smartphone use and
it's just terrible
for bed I think it makes sense because
if you think about our natural
biological rhythms when it comes to
sleep sure we'll start getting tired
what a few hours after the Sun sets
I guess because we're not like seeing
that sunlight and absorbing it as much
right so by the same token I think that
right before bed if you're looking at a
screen that's going to have the same
effect as being outside during the sunny
day like your melatonin is not gonna
kick in that's basically the idea yeah I
think that makes a lot of sense I think
it does too it's just not at all
surprising and I mean so many people are
on their phones in bed and I think it's
terrible my girlfriend will often do it
she'll be like watching videos and I'm
just like this is this this can't
continue this is you're not gonna like
this I do like to listen to something on
my phone like a long to our podcast and
for all asleep to it I wonder if that
has the same effect because I'm not
looking at the screen I just put it next
to me and kind of doze off it's kind of
like having the radio on and a lot of
people do that yeah except that I think
talk is not good for trying to go to
sleep if you have music that you're
listening to I think that that can be
helpful but I from what I recall
especially nonfiction talk is not the
greatest in the same way that reading
non-fiction books versus fiction before
before bed all else being equal for the
average person is considered not as good
yeah but you have no idea what thoughts
go on inside my head if I'm in complete
silence David and right there's no
there's no way I can fall asleep to that
I have to have something going on in the
background what about a white noise
machine hmm
or even like noise cancelling headphones
something like that well the headphones
can be uncomfortable so I don't know me
it'd be uncomfortable to wear headphones
but you can get for 30 bucks on Amazon
you can get a white noise machine the
type that like therapists use outside
their office to make it hard to hear the
conversations going on inside I have one
and it's great I I love it alright sign
me up for one of those yep I'll go to
amazon.com right now Pat's putting it on
his wish list okay that's it for today
we've got a new show tomorrow new bonus
show tomorrow no show Monday in light of
the story on today's show we are not
going off the air
just off on Monday for Memorial Day and
we'll do a show tomorrow and then we'll
talk to you on to the David Pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]